so you know having spent a little bit of
time at home now have you to have a
routine dev routine that you're doing to
kind of keep yourself motivated keep
yourself sane from morning tonight yes I
I usually do have a routine anyway but
what I do now now I'm kind of like in my
house I know I wake up I work out I make
some breakfast I put I get my like food
ready I'm very into my cooking at the
moment and so you know I have a studio
in my room so I kind of just put a mic
stand and a laptop so I'm so I'm just
taking it day by day and really going
slow pace which is a big big change for
me so I hope the family liked my cooking
because I've been doing a lot of that
you know one thing that's coming out of
this but I think was very a shift and
spotlight for people so
there's Paula going now on from my
workers people that are putting
themselves at risk
your mom is actually out there helping
doing this doing amazing things helping
people with their mental health yeah can
you explain to people what your mom
doesn't what she was doing out there
right now yes well it's a bit strange
because mom's and just wants to protect
them at all times you know and so my
mummy is very very strong she wakes up
everyday and is on the frontline works
for NHS so free health care in the UK
and she explains that it's very hectic
it's incredibly she's a psychiatrist for
free health care so what that means is
she goes in and she sort of tries to
mentally prepare and calm down and she's
very involved in all the patients
especially the hysteria that comes with
it all and the worry and the fear and
the anxiety so she's very very in tune
with that but obviously she's in contact
with a lot of patients and so every day
you know I'm not isolating with her but
she tells me she goes into the garage
part of the house and she takes off her
clothes and then she goes into the
shower and she does all the protocols
and things like that so I don't know
it's an intense time and I think for my
mum it almost feels like it's her duty
to do that you know and I think she
really thrives off doing her part she's
always been like that since I can
remember so I just give her that one one
a day cool like please be safe please
distantly surfacing as soon as you can
where you can and don't touch your face
and all that stuff and she says reader I
know I'm the doctor I get it but I just
can't help would be like ah come home
that would be great
obviously selfishly but at the same time
I understand that you know she really
wants to help the community and where
and what she's been doing for so long so
it said just think to see it firsthand
though you know yeah she must have
amazing stories about like very
resilient people and a lot of things
that people admire oh well yeah of
course there's a lot of people waiting
as well in the emergency room there's a
massive battle and we're just
guess she just says to me she tries to
get you know tries they trying it
through as many as possible you know
some wait long within two days you know
so it's just a lot going on yeah
and--but her role reversal to them I
mean like you you know from you know
worried about her checking in with her
versus the way that she would have done
with you going that right I know but all
she asks me to do is kind of you know
checking whether at the end of the day
and it's hard not going to see her you
know like I'm going to eat my mama's
food so I'm definitely like one missing
her food but also just missing that
interaction as we can all probably
understand but she just asked me like
what's good on the radio like what
storms have you been listening to what
can I listen to to take my mind off the
things she feels great you know I think
but you know just kind of being careful
isn't it yeah can you just listen to my
new song she said yeah but what else is
there she loves my kind of like sort of
like who to listen to and things like
that she's always very in tune with like
the young kids she likes to call it I
mean it takes on a whole new meaning now
yeah it's insane you know I put this
song out probably about over a month ago
before the strict rules of quarantine
but it was originally which it still is
a breakup song about you know not
feeling so crappy of about being on your
own after a breakup you know people get
that sort of like feeling of oh gosh
it's always so quiet I don't have a
companion I don't have my friend bagua
and that's coming from experience so
it's definitely a breakup song that has
that but now with everything happening
the song has become like almost like a
lift up for everyone that's
unfortunately kind of isolating alone so
it's really just taking the whole
different direction and I'm here for it
I mean whatever I gotta do to have
people kind of like feel better and it
an escapism I'm down so I'm happy I can
help people
yeah
you want escapism they got to watch the
video it's like this fever dream
it's like madness can I am um when they
said to you okay you're gonna be lying
down in a bunch of eggs
what was that you think let's do it like
smell bad after what's going on I mean
it smelled horrible afterwards it was
real eggs I was basically told okay
we're gonna put you in and you're gonna
step on them because metaphorically the
music video is all about metaphors so
that is a metaphor for walking on
eggshells obviously and kind of not
knowing where how the relationship is
and just kind of like questioning every
move and I wanted to literally show the
metaphors so I can't say because it'd be
inappropriate in this interview but I
had egg yolk and eggs in places that
were so crazy that I just can't believe
that I've even experienced it it took
forever to kind of come off it was crazy
but I do it anything for the art so I
wanted to do it and also the other
scenes where I'm hugging a real bear
which was like a real-life bear
obviously we shot the bear separately
and then she hired me in but it was
metaphor for wanting comfort from the
one thing that you know is really scary
and that could potentially kill you you
know love is a very strong drug and so
there's that and then there's another
one of you know ants on my face and
that's kind of like the frustration of
everything and not being able to shake
it off so yeah those are just a few
scenes from the video but you should
watch the rest yeah going deep metaphor
as I like it
are you finding now is a good time to
sort of refocus in terms of your music
is this affecting the way that you write
and the way that you approach creating a
hundred percent I think with this song
it's specific it wasn't necessarily part
of the album idea that I have in my mind
which I'm probably going to end up
putting out the beginning of next year
with everything going on
and just sort of doing it properly I
think that I wanted this song to stand
alone if this is what the song is about
because this is how I feel ill now kind
of with my process of writing I've
always been the person that has the same
kind of writers around and we bounce off
each other I've had my team for a long
time
I'm sending ideas over to producers
they're also sending things back to me I
have some incredible friends that are
just kind of wanting to make music
anyway so it's all kind of like being in
a big jam session right now because you
just have no pressure you know so I
think creatively it feels way more
authentic way more minimal way more
simple I have just like a mic in my
bedroom I'm taking it back to when I was
16 so it feels really good you know to
be able to not have pressure